PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Is your company
equipped to deal with software
development and delivery
as it adopts technologies
like containers, hybrid cloud,
or even multi-cloud?
Yes?
No?
Maybe?
Well, keep watching as we unwrap
the modern CI/CD with Anthos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Priyanka Vergadia,
and welcome to Anthos 101.
In this episode, we're talking
about all things CI/CD.
On your journey to
container adoption
across hybrid and
multi-cloud environments,
it is important
to think seriously
about continuous integration
and continuous delivery.
Oftentimes you will
see operations teams
getting bigger.
Security best practices
tougher to enforce over
more environments,
and reliability issues
making their way
into production.
So let's unwrap hybrid
and multi-cloud continuous
integration and
continuous delivery,
an approach that can help you
exhilarate your release cycles
and increase your software's
reliability across all
your environments.
Modern CI/CD on Anthos
embraces a shift left approach
to development and leverages
declarative templates
to manage security
policy, not people.
This means that issues are
addressed during build and test
phase, not in production.
It allows you to bring your
operations teams together,
cutting down on silos and
the proliferation of tools.
So let's dive in.
When we think about the
creation of a CI/CD pipeline,
there are three
different teams that
are involved, developers,
operators and security
engineers.
In this model, developers
have their own GIT repository
where they store their
application code.
That application code can kick
off continuous integration
whenever a developer
creates a commit, a change
to their application code.
A continuous integration
tool tests the code
and then creates an artifact.
When we're talking about
deploying to Kubernetes
clusters, our artifacts
are container images
that will eventually be
pushed to production.
Once continuous integration
creates that container image,
it will store it in
container registry.
The reference to the
recently stored image
will be stored in another
GIT repository controlled
by your application
operations team.
We'll call this the
deployment repo.
This secondary repository
holds Kubernetes manifests,
which have instructions
on how applications
should be configured.
In order to manage
that configuration,
we use a tool called Customize.
Customize packages together
the desired state container
image from our
container registry
and the instructions
from the Kubernetes
manifest, and store it in
the deployment repository.
This GIT repository
stores the state
that we want to deploy
into our environments.
The first place where
we store that state
is within the staging branch
of the deployment repository.
From that staging branch,
a continuous delivery tool
manages the deployment to
our staging environment,
where developers can
test this application.
With Anthos's
consistent platform,
the staging environments are
more similar to your production
environments.
Think about problems created
with different tools, practices
and processes when
testing in the cloud
and then pushing to
production in a totally
different environment.
When the developers
have finished testing,
they can tell the
operators that they
want to make a
push to production,
or the operators can
control the timing.
To push to production, they
march from the staging branch
of the deployment repository
into the master branch
and propagate those changes
into production environment.
For our security
teams, let's talk
a minute about how to secure
your production environments.
You also have your
own GIT repository
that is going to store the
expected state of the security
policies, things like
role-based access,
control policies, quotas
for your applications
and restricting risky
behavior, such as the ability
for containers to run as root.
How can you do that?
Well, one mechanism we use
is the policy controller,
which is a part of
Anthos Config Management.
Because of Anthos
consistent platform
across all of your
environments, security teams
can customize what policies
they want to run in what groups
of clusters.
And this is all done without
having to configure it
in each environment.
That was a quick
overview of modern CI/CD
on Anthos, showing how you
can increase your development
velocity and produce safe,
reliable applications
for your customers.
Ready to get started?
Check out the solutions
page linked below.
And for more Anthos
content, don't
forget to subscribe and follow
the Anthos 101 playlist.
[MUSIC PLAYING]